SENATORS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GAS.
BOOK WE GOT A CALL THE ROLL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THAT ALWAYS HELPS.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES.
BELL.
GORGEOUS BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CHIANG.
DODD.
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
WITH SO [inaudible] FOR TITLE
[inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE MITCHELL.
MONNING MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
ROTH.
RUBIO.
SKINNER.
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
NUMBER Y. CASKEY.
WIENER WILK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AS A SECRETARY
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS NOW PRESENT
AND WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GAS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE'LL BE LETTING PRAYER THIS
MORNING BY OUR AMAZING CHAPLAIN
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TODAY.
BY SENATOR HUESO.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE ONCE AGAIN.
GRACIOUS GOD HURT OF LOVE.
TEACHER OF THE WAYS OF GOODNESS.
YOU ARE HIDDEN IN THE POCKETS OF
DAILY LIFE WAITING TO BE
DISCOVERED.
HARD TO OF COMFORT.
REFUGE FOR SAD AND LONELY ONES.
YOU EMBRACE ALL WHO BEAR LOS.
GATHERING OUR TEARS WITH CARE.
PARTS OF UNDERSTANDING WHO GAZES
UPON THE M. PERFECT THE
INCOMPLETE.
THE FLOODS THE WEEK.
YOU NEVER STOP EXTENDING MERCY.
HEARTS OF GENEROSITY ABUNDANCE
OF INSIGHTS AND HOPE.
DALY YOU OFFER US GIFTS OF
GROWTH.
LEADING TO CONTINUAL
TRANSFORMATION.
HEARTS OF DEEP IS PLEASE.
RESTING PLACE OF THE CORE OF OUR
BEING.
YOU ARE WAITING ALWAYS FOR OUR
RETURN TO THIS SACRED HOME A MAN.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SOME OF THE
DONATIONS.
FOR BUT TO THE OF THE MATTER.
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH
YOU.
FOR INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU SISTER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE WE LIKE TO BETTER TURN
OUR ATTENTION TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR.
SENATOR GROVE HAS A VERY SPECIAL
INTRODUCTION TODAY WE LIKE TO
BETTER TURN THE FLOOR OVER.
TO SENATOR GROVE.
MEMBERS IF YOU CAN GIVE US
THIRTY SECONDS WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
SENATOR GROVE HAS A VERY SPECIAL
INTRODUCTION WEEK WELCOME.
MADAM LEADER TO THE FLOOR THE
FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I'M
SORRY FOR THE DELAY GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS -- I A HAVE A WONDERFUL
INTRODUCTION TODAY IT'S THE
MERION BERGESEN EXCELLENCE IN
PUBLIC SERVICES IS HIGHLY
REGARDED PROGRAM THAT SEEKS TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF WOMEN IN
ELECTED APPOINTED AND STAFF
POSITIONS.
AT THE LOCAL STATE AND FEDERAL
LEVERS LEVELS.
THE BERGESEN SCHOLARS BENEFIT
FROM TRAINING MENTORING AND
GREATLY EXPANDED NETWORK IN
RELATIONSHIPS THE SERIES IS A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE
TALENTED.
AMAZING WOMEN TO SERVE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
CANDACE BURROWS.
I HAVE LISA DAN SICK CECILIA
HONG.
ESTHER CO AMY WEST MARGARET
NOVAK AND ROOM NOW.
AND FRIEND ARE HE R. C. A. -- IF
KERN COUNTY IS BEAUTIFUL WIFE
MELISSA ALL SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ME IN WALKING THEM TO THE SENATE
FLOOR
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IF WE GET PLEASE HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION.
MEMBERS WE HAVE A SPECIAL
RESOLUTION THAT.
CENTER HUESO WOULD LIKE TO BE A
PRESENT MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
FORTY BY SENATOR HUESO RELATIVE
TO AUTISM AWARENESS MONTH.
THE MORNING CENTER WAY SO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR GOOD MORNING
THIS PRESIDENT IT SENATORS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT.
S. C. R. FORTY WHICH DESIGNATES
THE MONTH OF APRIL OF THIS YEAR
AS AUTUMN AUTISM AWARENESS MONTH.
AND IT ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS TO
SHOW SUPPORT FOR AUTISM
AWARENESS.
AUTISM AFFECTS CHILDRE FROM ALL
COUNTRIES NO MATTER THEIR GENDER
OR THEIR RACE OR SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS IT IS ESTIMATED HAT AS
HIGH AS TWO POINT 4% OF CHILDREN.
IN THE UNITED STATES SUFFER FROM
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDER.
YOUNG ADULTS WITH AUTISM ARE
LESS LIKELY LIKELY. TO CONTINUE
THEIR EDUCATION PAST SECONDARY
SCHOOL AND 35% OF YOUNG ADULTS
WITH AUTISM.
HAVE NOT HAD A JOB OR RECEIVED
POSTGRADUATE EDUCATION AFTER
LEAVING HIGH SCHOOL.
AUTISM AS YOU CAN EXPECT AFFECTS
PEOPLE FROM ALL BACKGROUNDS BUT
DISPROPORTIONATELY HIGHER.
IN IN HIGHER QUANTITIES.
AUTISM AFFECTS MINORITY AN
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN A WAY SO THAT I
COULD INTERRUPT MEMBERS WE HAVE
SEVERAL SIDE CONVERSATIONS ON
THE FLOOR AND WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS.
BUT YOU PLEASE TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO SENATOR HUESO TO BE
ABLE TO COMPLETE HIS
PRESENTATION ON THIS SPECIAL
RESOLUTION AND THANK YOU FOR
BOYFRIEND COUNTS IN A WAY SO
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU EVERYONE
FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
AGAIN IT AFFECTS DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES MORE SINCE
INDIVIDUALS.
OFTEN IT IN UNDERSERVED AREAS
HAVE LESS ACCESS TO SUPPORT
SERVICES AND CARE FOR THEIR
CHILDREN AND THEIR LOVED ONES.
TODAY I WANT TO THANK -- THE
SACRAMENTO AUTISM SPECTRUM AND
SPECIAL NEEDS ALLIANCE FOR
COMING HERE TODAY AND SUPPORTING
A RESOLUTION I AK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS RESOLUTION.
AND AND AND SOON I WILL LAST FOR
WARM WELCOME FOR OF PEOPLE OF
OUR COMMUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
FOR DOING WONDERFUL WORK.
WITH -- INDIVIDUALS ON THE
AUTISM.
SPECTRUM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER HUESO
WE'D LIKE TO BE A TO GO TO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR SENATOR PAN.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS I TO RISE IN ORDER TO
SEE OUR FORTY AND WATCHING MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRING YOUR FORD -- WE DEFINITELY
NEED TO RAISE.
AWARENESS OF AUTISM WE KNOW THAT --
THAT LACK OF AWARENESS ACTUALLY
LEAD TO UNDER DIAGNOSIS AND SO --
AND PARTICULARLY AMONG CHILDREN
OF COLOR AND SO THAT'S CERTAINLY
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO BE
SURE WE SCREEN IDENTIFY EARLY I
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOVERNOR IS
PROPOSING THAT WE THE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE DEVELOPS THE
SCREENING IS PART OF HIS --
PROPOSALS BUT ALSO MAKE NOTE
THAT THE ACTIONS THAT WE'VE
TAKEN HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE TO
ENSURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE MORE
SERVICES RIGHT.
SO WE'VE WE'VE PASSED LAWS TO
ENSURE THAT -- PEOPLE THAT
CHILDREN WITH AUTISM ARE ABLE
THAT HAVE TO GET COVERAGE FOR
THE SERVICES THEY GET -- OFTEN
TIMES -- THEY MAY NEED SPECIAL
EDUCATION AS WELL WE'RE DRESSING
THOSE THINGS AS WELL SO
CERTAINLY WE HAVE WORK TO DO TO
HELP.
FAMILIES OF CHILDREN WITH AUTISM --
BUT I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO
CELEBRATE SOME OF THE
COMPETITION IS THAT WE'VE DONE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP THOSE
FAMILIES AND WE CAN STILL
CONTINUE.
TO DO MORE BUT CERTAINLY
CALIFORNIA'S LEADER AND
APPRECIATE AGAIN MY GOOD FRIENDS
IN SAN DIEGO -- FOR BRING THIS
RESOLUTION BEFORE US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS TO
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CENTER HUESO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE -- JUST LIKE TO THANK
EVERYBODY IN THE DOCTOR'S
COMMENTS AND ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER WAY SO WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING A VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION
THAT WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR
BACK OVER TO CENTER HUESO TO BE
AND DO SOME VERY IMPORTANT GAS
IN.
THE BACK MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES.
HI BILL.
I POOR JUST.
BRADFORD.
I COME HERE ALL [inaudible]
BY CHIANG.
I DODD HI HI THERE ALSO.
HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO HI HI -- TADO.
JACKSON.
HI JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE.
PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
I LIKE COUNTY.
I WIENER AYE WILK.
HI.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE.
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
FURTADO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BOARD [inaudible]
PORTICI.
THIS IS RICKY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS WHO ONE MORE TIME
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA -- TADO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
SENATE HUESO MOVES THE CALL
CENTER HUESO WE'RE GONNA COME
BACK TO YOU FLOOR SHORES FORGETS
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU SIMPLY JUST TO
INTRODUCE THE SACRAMENT AUTISM
SPECTRUM AND SPECIAL NEEDS
ALLIANCE WHO ARE HERE TODAY --
TO RECEIVE OF THIS FOR THE
RESOLUTION ON BEHALF.
OF THE OF PEOPLE OF ALL TO SOME --
SPECTRUM -- IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO THANK
THEM FOR THEIR SERVICE TO THE
PEOPLE OF OUR STATE THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
WE INVITE ALL MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE TO BE ABLE TO JOIN AN
OFFICIAL PHOTOGRAPH
.
WELCOME TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
.
AND THE SENATORS ARE GONNA GIVE
IT ABOUT. THIRTY SECONDS
[inaudible]
NEVER GONNA.
TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR PAN IN
JUST A MOMENT.
WE HAVE A FEW LAST GOODBYES IN
THE BACK IN.
WE THEN WILL NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH OUR FLOOR
SESSION FOR THIS THURSDAY -- THE
WHOLE WORLD
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
SENATORS.
IF WE CAN HAVE ALL OF YOUR
ATTENTION.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
CENTER PLANNED THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
I THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATORS.
AS WE KNOW THE DEMOCRACY
REQUIRES THAT WE HEAR TO
PETITIONS OF THE PEOPLE OF THE
STATE AND YESTERDAY MANY OF THEM
CAME TO THE CAPITOL THIS YEAR --
TO GIVE THEIR OF SHARE THEIR
OPINIONS WITH US ABOUT THE
VARIOUS ISSUES BEFORE US.
AND BUT THAT CAN BE VERY
CHALLENGING GIVEN THE NATURE OF
THE SPACE AND BE SURE WE
MAINTAIN ORDER IN THE BUILDING
SO.
I JUST WANTED TO AND I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THANK OUR SENATE SERGEANTS FOR
AN AMAZING JOB YESTERDAY AND
COULD BE FAIRLY TRYING
CIRCUMSTANCES.
IN THIS BUILDING BUT ENSURING
THAT EVERYONE GOT THEIR VOICE
HEARD THAT WE MAINTAIN ORDER BUT
PEOPLE GOT THE CHANCE TO HAVE
THEIR SAY HERE IN THE CAPITAL SO
AGAIN I WANT THINK OF SENATE
SERGEANTS FOR AN OUTSTANDING JOB.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER PAN
WE'RE GRATEFUL.
TO THE SERGEANTS FOR ALL THE
WORK THEY DO DAY IN DAY OUT FOR
THE ENTIRE STAFF TEAM AS WELL.
CENTER LEYVA ON THIS ITEM YES
PLEASE WHICH AT THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I TO WANT TO THANK THE
SERGEANTS AND THEN IF YOU DIDN'T
SEE TEAM LABOR BROUGHT YOU A
BUNCH OF GOODIES SO GO ENJOY
SOMETHING.
IT WAS A LONG DAY YESTERDAY WE
APPRECIATE YOU [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO GO BACK
TO FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY TWO WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
LIFT THE CALL.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA -- TADA.
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
I ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED WE DO HAVE
A FULL HOUSE MEMBERS.
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE ON
ITEM NUMBER.
FOUR THAT'S MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THOSE MESSAGES WILL BE
DEEMED READ.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS IN
NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR APRIL TWENTY SECOND
THROUGH THE TWENTY FIFTH. TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WILL BE USED
APPROVED AND CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
RIGHT NOW GOING TO TURN THE
FLOOR OVER TO THE MAJORITY
LEADER MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
I'D LIKE TO READ REQUEST REMOVAL
OF SP SIX SEVENTY ONE ITEM
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED FROM THE
CONSENT FILE THANK YOU ERY MUCH
THANK YOU SO MUCH MR MAJORITY
LEADER DESK WILL TAKE NOTE
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
KNOW THAT WE ARE AT THE END OF A
LONG WEEK WE ARE A CHATTY BUNCH
THIS THURSDAY WE HAVE HAD OUR
CAFFEINE.
I WOULD LIKE EVERYONE TO PLEASE
KEEP YOUR CONVERSATIONS TO A
MINIMUM AS WE'RE GOING TO BE.
MOVING INTO OUR DAILY FILE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO BE
TAKING A LOOK AT THE SECOND
READING FILE.
BUT YOUR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS TO TEN WITH THE
MOMENTS THREE SIXTY NINE WITH
MOMENTS ONE SEVENTY TWO WITH THE
MEMBERS FOR NINETY WITH AMOUNTS
FOR FIFTY THREE WITH THE MOMENT
SIX SIXTY THREE THE MOMENTS.
THAT OF A SECOND READING FILES
TEAM READ THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE.
SEVERAL ITEMS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
UNDER THIRD READING TODAY.
THE MAJORITY LEADER OF THE
WORKING WITH YOU TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE IS PREPARED AND READY
TO GO.
WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING UP ITEMS
THIRTY FIVE THROUGH EIGHTY SEVEN
TODAY.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE ME TO START
WITH ITEM THIRTY FIVE SENATOR
PAN.
DINNER PAN IS PASS ON FILE.
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX CENTER GALGIANI PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE TURNING
OUR ATTENTION ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR RUBIO YOU
PREPARE TO PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE THANK YOU MADAM
SENATOR.
FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT MAJORITY
LEADER HERTZBERG.
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT MISTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT RULING
TO PREACH ARE RELEASED GOOD
MORNING MR MAJORITY LEADER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS PRESIDENT.
TO TOGETHER WITH SENATOR
MITCHELL WE ARE JOINT AUTHORS OF
THIS MEASURE.
SB THIRTY SIX IS A BILL INSPIRED
BY A NATIONAL MOVEMENT FOCUSED
ON REFORMING OUR PRE TRIAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
CROSS THIS COUNTRY POLICY
INNOVATORS IN SYSTEM ACTORS ARE
RETHINKING HOW WE ACHIEVE EQUITY
FOR THE ACCUSED IN THE PERIOD
BETWEEN WHEN THEY ARE CHARGED
WITH A CRIME.
AND WHEN THEY ARE BROUGHT TO
TRIAL.
IN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES ALREADY
HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTING
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN THEIR PRE
TRIAL.
SYSTEMS FORTY NINE OF OUR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES MISTER PRESIDENT.
HAVE ADOPTED PRE TRIAL RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS AIMED AT
IMPROVING JUDICIAL DECISION
MAKING IN PRE TRIAL SUPERVISION
PRACTICES.
THE PROBLEM OF COURSE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO WHICH WE ARE
SEEKING TO TO REPAIR WITH THIS
MEASURE.
IS A THE TOOLS COME IN ALL
SHAPES AND SIZES THEIR PRODUCE
IN ALL MANNERS OF ORGANIZATIONS
FROM FOR PROFIT COMPANIES TO
CHARITABLE FOUNDATIONS AND THE
VERY DRAMATICALLY IN THE
METHODOLOGY THE USED TO
CALCULATE.
RISK OF SOMEONE CHARGED WITH A
CRIME.
MORE CONCERNING IS THE FACT THAT
UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW OUR CURRENT
LAW THERE ARE NO MINIMUM
STANDARDS ARE REPEAT MEMBERS
THERE ARE NO MINIMUM STANDARDS
GOVERNING THE EFFECTIVE USE OF
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS AND NO
SAFEGUARDS.
IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE
BEING USED IN A WAY THAT
ACCURATELY ESTIMATES THE RISK
WHILE MINIMIZING BIAS.
ARE STRESS MINIMIZING BIAS WITH
THIS MEASURE WE ARE CREATING
THREE MINIMUM STANDARDS
REGARDING THE USE OF RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS. ONE ANY COUNTY
THAT USES A TOOL MUST VALIDATE
THE TO ON A REGULAR BASIS THAT
MEANS EVERY SIX MONTHS. TO ANY
TOOL USED IN CALIFORNIA MUST BE
TRANSPARENT.
THAT MEANS IT COUNTIES NEED TO
TELL THE PUBLIC EXACTLY HOW THE
RISK CORES ARE BEING CALCULATED.
THREE COUNTIES DE TO COLLECT
RETAIN AND PUBLISH DATA ON THEIR
PRE TRIAL RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS
SO THAT THEY CAN BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE COMMUNITIES.
THAT THEY SERVE MEMBERS THE
REALITY IS THAT IN CALIFORNIA
WHEN IT COMES TO THE WAY WE
HANDLE THE ACCUSED BEFORE TRIAL.
WE ARE FAILING.
AT NIGHT TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
REPORT BY THE PRE TRIAL JUSTICE
IS TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE PRE
TRIAL JUSTICE SYSTEMS IN ALL
FIFTY STATES.
MEMBERS.
WE IN CALIFORNIA RECEIVED A D..
A DE.
WE CAN DO BETTER WE MUST DO THE
BALLOT.
IN DEVELOPING THIS MEASURE WE
HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH A GROUP
OF SPONSORS THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
CALIFORNIA'S FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION.
NEXT GEN AMERICA S. CI YOU
CALIFORNIA ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR OF SENATOR MITCHELL.
FLOOR IS YOURS MA'AM.
GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'D STOOD ON
THE FLOOR AS WE DEBATED THE BAIL
BILL LAST YEAR -- WHEN SOME
FOLKS HAD SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE FINAL VERSION OF THE BILL
AND WHETHER OR NOT?
IT WAS TIMELY WEATHER NOT IT WAS
COOKED YET AND SAID THAT I WOULD
STAND WITH MISTER HERTZBERG
AGAIN.
THIS YEAR TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
GET IT RIGHT.
AND I BELIEVE SB THIRTY SIX IS
THE APPROPRIATE NEXT STEP IN
GUARANTEEING THAT WE GET IT
RIGHT.
WE CAN DEBATE THE INHERENT BIAS
OF RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS FRANKLY
UNTIL THE COWS COME HOME.
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS
THAT ANY PREDICTIVE TOOL WE USE
IN ANY PART OF OUR LIVES IS IN
SOME WAY GOING TO USE THE PASS.
TO SHED LIGHT ON THE FUTURE.
THIS IS TRUE WHEN JUDGES LOOK AT
RAPSHEETS TO MAKE A BILL
DETERMINATION ARE WHEN
ECONOMISTS LOOK AT BOOM AND BUST
CYCLES TO TRY AND PREDICT THE
NEXT RECESSION.
WE HAVE A CHOICE WE CAN GIVE
INTERFERE CENSORSHIP SYSTEM
ACTORS OF A VALUABLE TOOL THAT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO PROTECT
INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY OR WE CAN DO
THE HARD WORK OF BUILDING IN
SAFEGUARS TO MAKE SURE THIS
TOOL IS USE THE RIGHT WAY.
THERE'S THIS HOVERING FEAR OUT
THERE ABOUT THE USE OF MACHINES
AND YOU'LL READ IT FROM BOTH
CRITICS.
AND SUPPORTERS ON BOTH SIDES
THAT IF WE ALLOW COURTS AND
COUNTIES TO USE THESE TOOLS WILL
BE LEADING MACHINES MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT OUR LIBERTY.
THE CRITICS ARE WRONG.
THESE MACHINES DO NOT MAKE
RELEASE OR DEATH THE TENSION
DECISIONS.
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS ARE
EXACTLY THAT THEY ARE TOOLS
ADDING MORE TOOLS TO THE JUDGES
TOOL BOX WILL ENHANCE THEIR
DECISION MAKING.
BROADEN THEIR UNDERSTANDING OF
AN INDIVIDUAL CIRCUMSTANCES BY
BRINGING DATA AND EVIDENCE INTO
THE EQUATION FOR THOSE REASONS I
PROBABLY STAND AS PRINCIPAL
COOPER AND WILL BE VOTING TODAY
TO SUPPORT.
SB.
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS CENTER MITCHELL.
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO OPEN UP FOR
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE SOME MAJORITY
LEADER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
AYE VOTE PLEASE THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH RICHER SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BELL.
I FOR JUST BY BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG AYE DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
BY JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BYE BYE MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL.
HI NIELSEN.
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WINNER BY WILK.
HI.
MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE AND THEN.
CLOSE IT DOWN MR SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA.
JONES HI.
EYES THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS IS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE SENATOR CHANGE PREPARE TO
RESENT SHE IS.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIXTY FOUR BY
SENATOR CHIANG AND ACT REALLY IN
ANIMALS.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR CHIANG.
GOOD MORNING MISTER PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES SB SIXTY FOUR
REQUIRES ALL MUNICIPAL ANIMAL
SHELTERS AS SPECIFIED MICROCHIP.
ANY DOG OR CAT WITH CURRENT
INFORMATION THAT IS EITHER
ADOPTED OR CLAIM BY A PET OWNER.
THIS WILL ULTIMATELY SAVE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYER DOLLARS BY
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING THE
AMOUNT OF EUTHANIZED.
AND SHELTER DOGS AND CATS.
SB SIXTY FOUR IS NEARLY
IDENTICAL TO SB SEVEN OH TWO OF
TWENTY ELEVEN THAT PASSED
THROUGH WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
OUT OF THE OVER SIX MILLION
ANIMALS THAT ARE SHELTERED
NATIONWIDE APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION SHELTER DOGS
AND CATS LOSE THEIR LIVES
EUTHANASIA.
IN CALIFORNIA HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS SHELTER DOGS AND CATS
ARE EUTHANIZED EVERY YEAR.
A SIGNIFICANT SOURCE OF THE
PROBLEM IS I AND WANT
IDENTIFICATION AND THE ABILITY
TO REUNITE THESE ANIMALS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES.
ONLY 15% OF DOGS AND 2% OF CATS
IN SHELTERS WITHOUT
IDENTIFICATION REUNIFIED WITH
THEIR OWNERS.
BY CONTRAST ACCORDING TO THE
JOURNAL OF THE AMERICAN
VETERINARY MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
ALMOST 75%.
OF LOS MICROCHIP CATS AND DOGS
WERE LOCATED DUE TO THE PRESENCE
OF THE MICROCHIP. FOR EXAMPLE
DURING THE CAMP FIRE THE FIRE
SPREAD SO FAST THAT PEOPLE
BARELY HAD TIME TO SAVE
THEMSELVES LET LET ALONE THERE
PAT.
AS A RESULT OVER THE FOLLOWING
WEEKS FIRST RESPONDERS CARRY
THOUSANDS OF INJURED AND
DISPLACED ANIMALS EMERGENCY
VETERINARY HOSPITALS.
AND EMERGENCY ANIMAL SHELTERS IT
WAS REPORTED THAT THE LOOKING
ANIMALS AND ALREADY HAD THE
MICROCHIP IN IMPLANTED WERE
SAVED IN THAT WITHOUT MICHAEL TO
FOR TAGS THE IDENTIFICATION
PROCESS COULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF THE INJURY
SUCH AS THE WHISKERS BEING
SINGED OFF.
OF YOURS PAINFULLY BURNED AT THE
EDGES INFERS FOR WISHING FOR
TREATMENT SO BASICALLY SOME OF
THEM WERE UNRECOGNIZABLE.
WITH THIS BILL WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US. TO TO BE
ABLE TO SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE THE
AMOUNT OF DOGS AND CATS THAT
WIND UP IN SHELTERS TO BE
EUTHANIZED.
BOTTOM LINE WE ARE SAVING LIVES
AND TAXPAYER DOLLARS WITH THIS
BILL AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SENATOR DO WE
HAVE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR SENATOR HUESO.
JUST SIMPLY RISE IN SUPPORT OF
OF SB SIXTY FOUR THIS IS A
WONDERFUL BILL -- I HAD A
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH THE PAT
IN WITH THAT WAS -- GIVEN
IMPLANT AND THIS PET WAS --
PARTICULARLY -- ADVENTUROUS.
AND THE HAD A HARD TIME STAYING
IN THE HOME BECAUSE HE WAS --
VERY VERY ADVENTUROUS PAT FACT
HE WAS KNOWN. TO TO NOT ONLY
LEAVE THE HOME BUT ENTER THE
TROLLEY.
IN THIS FOR THIS PAT OF FOUND
ITS WAY FROM MY HOME IN SAN
DIEGO TO FRESNO.
AND BECAUSE OF THE CHIP WE WERE
WE WERE RELOCATED HE WAS WE WERE
REUNITED HE WAS REUNITED WITH
OUR FAMILY.
AND AND HE HAS BEEN A MEMBER OF
OUR FAMILY SENSE THANKS TO THE
CHIP.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT HE
WAS ADVENTURES TELL YOU HAD A
HARD TIME STAYING IN THE HOME.
AND A LOT OF THESE PETS THAT.
HAVE ADVENTURES PERSONALITIES
COULD BE.
WELL SIR BY THIS PROGRAM AND I
THINK THE OVERALL PROGRAM WOULD
BE SERVED BY BY THIS SO I RISE.
IN SUPPORT OF THIS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH IN A WAY SO THAT IS
ONE HECK OF A DRIVE FOR THE DOCK.
SO MY GOODNESS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE
TO BE TO SEE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER
CHANGE LIKE CLOSE PLEASE I SWUNG
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR HIS
WONDERFUL STORY IN SUPPORT AND
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATORS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION USING OR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION.
I THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO OF THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS ARE NOW THAT WE HAVE TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER FORTY
SENATOR PAN.
PASS ON FILE ITEM NUMBER FORTY
ONE SENATOR LEYVA.
PASS ON FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
SENATOR PAINE.
PASS ON FILE MEMBERS WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE REMOVED ITEM
FORTY THREE SENATORS SKINNER.
PASS ON FILE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GOING TO JUMP
PASSED FORTY FOUR AND FORTY FIVE
AS WE HAVE AMENDMENTS PINDI.
WE'RE NOT GONNA MOVED ITEM FORTY
SIX SENATOR HUESO.
PASS ON FILE MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
STICK WITH SENATOR HUESO ITEM
NUMBER.
FORTY SEVEN PASS ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER FORTY EIGHT SENATOR
PORTANTINO.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM FORTY NINE IS NOT ELIGIBLE
TO MOMENT WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ADVANCE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY THAT'S GOING TO BE A PASS
ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTY ONE CENTER
WIENER WE HAVE A WINNER LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN.
WE'RE NOW GOING TO READ MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ
ITEM NUMBER.
FIFTY ONE SENATE BILL THIRTY BY
SENATOR WIENER AN ACT RELATING
TO DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP.
GOOD MORNING CENTER WINNER THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR I THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES
ARE SENATE BILL -- THIRTY WILL
AND DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES IN
CALIFORNIA'S DOMESTIC PARTNER
REGISTRY.
WHEN THE DOMESTIC PARTNER
REGISTER WAS CREATED IN
CALIFORNIA IT WAS LIMITED TO
SAME SEX COUPLES BECAUSE WE
COULD NOT GET MARRIED AT THAT
POINT IN TIME -- AS WELL AS
OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES AGE SIXTY
TWO AND OLDER. FOR SOCIAL
SECURITY REASONS NOW OF COURSE
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA CAN GET
MARRIED.
ABOUT THE DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIP
REGISTRY IS STILL EXCLUDES
OPPOSITE SEX COUPLES UNDER THE
AGE OF SIXTY TWO SO THIS BILL
AND THAT DISCRIMINATION -- AND
PROVIDE THAT ANYONE WHO WANTS TO
BECOME A DOMESTIC PARTNER GAY
STRAIGHT OR ANYONE ELSE -- IS
ABLE TO DO SO -- RELATIONSHIPS
TAKE ALL SORTS OF DIFFERENT
FORMS AND MODERN LIFE AND WE
SHOULD ALLOW PEOPLE TO MAKE
THESE CHOICES FOR THEMSELVES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
RIVERS WE LIKELY TO SEE IF WE
HAVE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
JONES GOOD MORNING SIR THE FLOOR
IS YOURS [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES -- I'VE THERE'S SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT SOME OF THE
LANGUAGE IN THE AMENDMENTS.
AND MAYBE THE PRISONER CAN IN
HIS CLOTHES TALK ABOUT THE FEES
THAT.
COULD BE.
KEY IS A TAX.
AND SO I THINK SOME OF US ARE
GONNA LAY OFF THE BILL TODAY.
BUT WE WOULD BE INTERESTED TO
HEAR.
MAYBE HOUSE CAN BE HANDLED --
MOVING FORWARD FROM HERE THANK
YOU -- I'M SORRY ONE MORE THING.
THE THE PRINCIPLE OF THE BILL IS
SUPPORTABLE WE JUST HAVE SOME --
CHALLENGES WITH THE AMENDMENT
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SAID JONES.
MEMBERS.
LOOKING FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THIS TIME.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
CENTER WINNER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE PLEASE I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT --
COLLEAGUES THE FEES THAT WERE --
A PARTNER -- DOMESTIC PARTNERS
WILL HAVE TO PAY TO BECOME THE
BEST PARTNERS ARE THE IDENTICAL
FEES THAT ARE ALREADY BEING PAID
IT'S A THIRTY THREE DOLLAR FEE.
THE TEN DOLLAR ADMINISTRATIVE
FEE AND TWENTY THREE DOLLARS
THAT GOES INTO A FIND TO PREVENT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
THESE ARE THE FEES THAT SAME SEX
COUPLES HEY RIGHT NOW AND HAVE
BEEN PAYING.
AND IT WOULD SIMPLY SAY THAT FOR
THESE NEW DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WERE ALLOWING TO HAPPEN.
THEY WILL PAY THE SAME EXACT FEE --
YOU CAN KEY THAT MEANS HERE
WHATEVER WE WANT TO KIA -- BUT
THIS IS THE SAME EXACT THE THAT
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS ARE PAYING
RIGHT NOW AND HAVE BEEN PAYING
FOR YEARS SO THERE'S NO CHANGE
OUR I RESPECTFULLY ASK BROUGH.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
BY GORGEOUS [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
BY DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI.
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
BY JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
HI MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
BY KATHY.
BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI [inaudible]
LATE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE IT
DOWN MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA.
BATES [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
HI.
HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE IN ITEM FIFTY
TWO CENTER GALGIANI IS READY TO
ROLL MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL SIXTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR GALGIANI AN ACT
RELATING TO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM SENATOR THE
MORNING THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
TO MEMBERS I RISE TODAY PRESENT
SB SIXTY EIGHT SB SIXTY EIGHT
WOULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL. TO
INCLUDE A CURRENT AND UPDATED
LIST OF APPROVED LANDFILLS THAT
EXCEPT TREATED WOOD WASTE ON
THEIR WEBSITE.
TREATED WOOD IS A COMMONLY USED
MATERIAL IN CONSTRUCTION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE WHERE EXPOSURE TO
MOISTURE INSECTS OR OTHER
ELEMENTS COMPROMISE THE WOODS
STRENGTH AND USEFUL LIFE.
THIS BILL WOULD ENSURE THAT AN
UPDATED LIST OF APPROVED
LANDFILLS IS READILY ACCESSIBLE
TO THE PUBLIC SB EIGHT SIX SB
SIXTY EIGHT ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
SENATORS WE HAVE A DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
HEARING SEEN NINE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION AYE
AYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
WERE NOW DANCING TO ITEM FIFTY
THREE SENATOR WINNER YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE.
MEMBERS ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM FIFTY FOUR SENATOR DODD IS
PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR DODD AN ACT RELATING
TO ELECTRICITY.
THE MORNING SENATOR DOT
[inaudible]
ELECTRICITY.
YES -- MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SP ONE SIXTY SEVEN ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE OF HOW UTILITIES ASSIST
CUSTOMERS PARTICULARLY LOW
INCOME CUSTOMERS WHO RELY ON
LIFE SUPPORT EQUIPMENT.
WHEN THE UTILITY DE ENERGIZES
POWER LINES TO PROTECT AGAINST
WILDFIRE IGNITION?
LAST YEAR'S ESPY NOT A ONE
REQUIRES ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
PREPARE WILD FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS THAT INCLUDE PROTOCOLS FOR
DE ENERGIZING POWER LINES.
IT IS LIKELY WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
IN THE ESTABLISH MENTOR OF
FORMAL PROTOCOLS TO DE ENERGIZED --
POWER LINES THE FREQUENCY OF
POWER OUTAGES WILL CONTINUE TO
GROW.
DE ENERGIZING OF ELECTRICAL
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
EQUIPMENT CREATES CERTAIN RISKS
OF ITS OWN AMONG THOSE RISK IS
INTERRUPTION OF POWER NEEDED TO
OPERATE -- CUSTOMER BASE LIFE
SUPPORT EQUIPMENT.
AMONG THOSE RISKS.
EXCUSE ME -- MANY OF THESE
CRITICAL CARE CUSTOMERS ARE LOW
INCOME INTO OF ALREADY RECEIVE
DISCOUNTS UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE RADIATOR G. CARE
PROGRAM.
I BELIEVE IT IS A MATTER OF
HEALTH AND SAFETY TO ASSIST LOW
INCOME CRITICAL CARE MEDICAL
BASE LIKE CUSTOMERS IN THE
PROVISION OF EMERGENCY BACKUP
POWER.
THEY CAN OPERATE LIFE SUPPORT
EQUIPMENT FOR THE DURATION OF
THE POWER OUTAGE.
SB ONCE SIX SEVEN SIMPLY
REQUIRES AN ELECTRICAL UTILITY
TO DETERMINE HOW IT WANTS TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE AND DESCRIBE
IT SOLUTION IN THAT PART OF ITS
WILD FIRE MITIGATION PLAN.
THE PER TEN PER PERTAINS TO
ENERGIES ENERGY.
ENERGY IS A SIN -- PROTOCOLS SO --
WITH THAT THERE'S NO OPPOSITION
ON THE BILL AND A RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD.
SENATORS WILL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE WE DO HAVE A FEW WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SENATOR STONE AND
THEN SENATOR STERN.
FINISHED ON THE FLOOR IS YOURS
SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
WANT -- TO APPLIED MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR DODD FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS WE ALL KNOW WE HAVE A
RAPIDLY AGING POPULATION AND
MANY OF OUR AGING -- COLLEAGUES
AND FRIENDS -- RETIRE TO
MOUNTAINOUS RURAL AREAS -- FOR A
QUIET RETIREMENT -- BUT AS WE
AGE WE REQUIRE EQUIPMENT THAT
OFTEN REQUIRES ELECTRIFICATION --
WHICH INCLUDES -- OXYGEN
CONCENTRATORS -- I ALSO HAVE A A
NUMBER OF DEVELOP MANY DISABLED
CONSTITUENTS IT REQUIRE
RESPIRATORS -- THAT NEED
ELECTRICITY TO RECHARGE THEIR
BATTERIES IF THEIR BATTERIES GO
AND THEY HAVE NO WAY TO RECHARGE
THOSE BATTERIES THE RESULT IS
DEATH.
SO THIS IS A VERY PROACTIVE BILL --
PARTNERING WITH THE UTILITIES TO
IDENTIFY THOSE PEOPLE AT RISK
AND ENSURE THAT IF WE HAVE SOME
OF THE HORRIFIC -- DISASTROUS
FIRES THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN
THE PAST SO WE WILL HAVE BACKUP
GENERATORS OR SOME OTHER FORM OF
ALTERNATIVE ENERGY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE SUSTAIN THEIR LIVES
UNTIL SUCH TIME.
THAT THE UTILITY.
GUARANTEE THEM SAFE
ELECTRIFICATION WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AND URGED AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR CENTERS
TURN THE FLOOR IS YOURS FAMOUS
PRESENT I JUST WANT TO RISE
BRIEFLY IN SUPPORT AND SAY THAT
IS A CRITICAL FIRST STEP IN.
PREVENTING THE IMPACTS OF P. S.
P. S. THAT WE KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO CONTINUE FOR GOING TO
PREVNT WILDFIRES PRACTICALLY
BUT WE NEED TO GO EVEN FURTHER I
BELIEVE -- THIS THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
MEDICAL BASS LINE COMMUNITY.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FIRE
STATIONS THAT LOST POWER -- THE
HOSPITAL'S AN URGENT CARE
CENTERS AND JUST AVERAGE
CITIZENS HAVE BEEN GOING THROUGH
THIS THROUGHOUT THE STATE I
REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH CERTAIN DODD THE
REST OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE IN.
AN EXPANDING UPON THIS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FIRST STEP
THANKS THANK YOU MISTER CENTER.
MEMBERS LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE.
XENON CENTER DODD WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZE SEEN OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON ITEM.
FIFTY FOUR HEARING SEE NO
OBJECTION EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE NOW
WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCED ITEM FIFTY FIVE CENTER
JACKSON PASS ON FILE.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO MOVE DIED
IN FIFTY SIX THE MAJORITY LEADER
CENTER HERTZBERG PREPARED TO
PRESENT MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL ONE NINETY TWO
BY SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATED CRIMES.
MR MAJORITY LEADER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
YOU KNOW.
I SUSPECT THAT EACH OF US.
THROUGHOUT THIS CHAMBER HAD
INTERNS IN THEIR OFFICE.
WHO ALWAYS HAVE INTERESTING
IDEAS AND LIKE TO ENGAGE IN A
THOUGHTFUL WAY?
WE HAD A DISCUSSION ONE DAY IN
MY OFFICE WITH THE SERIES OF
INTERNS.
AND THEY TALKED ABOUT HOW MANY
TIMES WE PASS LAWS WHY DON'T WE
TAKE A LAW OFF THE BOOKS.
SO I EMPLOYED THEM TO GO THROUGH
ALL TWENTY NINE CODES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND LOOK FOR INTERESTING THINGS
THAT THEY MIGHT BE ABLE TO TAKE
OFF THE BOOKS.
IT IS SO INTERESTING TO FIND
THAT WHEN YOU THINK THINGS THAT
ARE.
DON'T LOOK LIKE THEY'RE A
PROBLEM THEY TURN OUT THEY HAVE
A CONSTITUENCY THERE'S A PROBLEM.
BUT WE FOUND THE THAT THERE'S A
PROHIBITION FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
EYE GLASSES ONE CAN WEAR WHEN
THEY DRIVE OR THE LIGHTING
REQUIRED A NOW DEFUNCT WOULDN'T
RIVER BARGES.
BUT THE ONE THAT CAUGHT OUR
ATTENTION IN THE ONE THAT I
BRING TO YOU TODAY.
IS REPEALING THE EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO LAW THE POSSE
COMITATUS ACT OF EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO PENAL CODE SECTION
ONE FIFTY MAKES IT A CRIME.
LADIES AND GENTLEMAN FOR ANYONE
OVER THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA TO WILLFULLY OR
NEGLIGENT REFUSED TO JOIN A
POSSE.
AND IMPOSE A FINE OF A THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND WITH ASSESSMENTS AS
WELL MORE LIKE THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
NOW WE KNOW THAT THROUGHOUT OUR
HISTORY WE'VE ADOPTED THE POSSE
POWER IN THE EARLIEST DAYS OF
OUR REPUBLIC.
IN DECADES THAT FOLLOWED WAS
MOST NOTABLY USED TO PRESERVE
THE PEACE ON THE WESTERN FRONT.
AND QUITE SURPRISINGLY IS WE
REACHED WITH IT WENT THROUGH THE
HISTORY TO APPREHEND SOLD RUN
AWAY SLAVES.
BUT A LOCAL GRANT OF POWER THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN NECESSARY DURING A
TIME OF LAWLESS FRONT TWO YEARS
AND WHEN THE SOCIETY WAS QUITE
DIFFERENT.
WAS NOT SIMPLY RELEVANT TODAY IN
MODERN TIMES.
WE ARE PROFESSIONAL POOL POLICE
FORCES THAT USE INCREDIBLE
TECHNOLOGY INVESTIGATIVE MATH
METHODOLOGIES TO SOLVE CRIMES WE
DON'T NEED CRIMINAL LIABILITY
HANGING OVER CITIZENS.
HEADS TO COURSE THEM TO
ASSISTING POLICE.
AND I WANT TO MAKE 6 THING
PERFECTLY CLEAR BY REMOVING THIS
SECTION FROM THE PENAL CODE WE
ARE NOT SAYING.
THAT CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT
HELP FIRST RESPONDERS AND THEIR
FELLOW CITIZENS WHEN OBLIGATED
BY EITHER STATUTORY OR MORAL
DUTY WE HAVE A GOOD SAMARITAN
LAW IN CALIFORNIA THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE.
WE ARE PROVISIONS IN GOVERNMENT
CODES AND PENAL CODES I DON'T
DROOL THROUGH ALL OF THEM BUT
THEY'RE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
THE BOTTOM LINE OF WHICH IMPOSE
ON A DUTY BUT NOT CRIMINAL
LIABILITY.
AND I MENTIONED ALSO THE FEES
AND SO THE LAWS A VESTIGE OF A
BY GONE ERA.
AND WHAT INVOKE SUBJECTS
CALIFORNIANS TO AN UNTENABLE
MORAL DILEMMA.
JOINT AND POTENTIALLY PUT ONE'S
LIFE AT RISK OR REFUSE TO BECOME
A CRIMINAL.
THIS LAW IS DEAD LETTER IT IS IT
USE IT IS NEEDED THIS IS ONE WE
CAN TAKE OFF THE BOOKS I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE [inaudible]
SENATORS.
TWEET DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN NINE MEMBERS.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
UTILIZING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL AND I'M.
FIFTY SIX HEARING SEEN NINE EYES.
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WE LIKE TO ADVANCE ITEM
FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR HILL.
CENTER HILLS PASS ON FILE.
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR GROVE.
PASS ON FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE
SENATOR HERTZBERG.
CENTER HERTZBERG IS PREPARED TO
PRESENT MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 229%
HERTZBERG AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT.
MR MAJORITY LEADER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT ALL
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I
AUTHORED SB THREE OH SIX TO
PROTECT THE WORKERS RIGHT. TO
REPORT WORKPLACE VIOLATIONS IT
WAS ABOUT BEING A WHISTLE BLOWER
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT THOSE BIG
CHARGE THAT WE HAVE IN OUR
OFFICE THAT SET FORTH THE RIGHTS
OF EMPLOYEES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES EMPLOYEES.
RIGHT THERE ON THAT CHART IS A
VERY DIRECT STATEMENT TALKING
ABOUT IS THE IMPORTANT PUBLIC
POLICY OF CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT
WHISTLEBLOWERS IN THE WORKPLACE.
BOB WHEN THIS MEASURE TOOK THIS
YEAR I'VE BEEN A JUSTICE MEASURE
TO SOLIDIFY THOSE RIGHTS AND
STRENGTH IN THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER'S ABILITY TO CARRY
OUT.
ADJUST LITIGATION PROCESS
SPECIFICALLY THIS MEASURE
CLARIFIES THAT ONCE A CITATION
BECOMES FINAL CITATION BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR BECOME LAW
FINAL THE LABOR COMMISSIONER CAN
EFFECTUATE THE RELIEF FOR THE
WHISTLE BLOWER. TO CRITICAL
CHANGE IN ORDER TO EXPEDITE THE
PROCESS CONSISTENT WITH THE
UNDERLYING ASPECT OF THE LAW
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE DONE TO
CLARIFY WHAT IS ALREADY IN
STATUTE AND WHAT WE HAD
INTRODUCED BEFORE I ASK. FOR
YOUR I BOUGHT.
SENATORS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE IS THERE ANY SKEWS ME.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
BY BATES [inaudible]
BELL.
BY FOR JUST.
HI BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
HI CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI FI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON.
HI JONES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
LABOR.
I AM A CHOIR [inaudible]
I MITCHELL.
I MONNING.
I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE.
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
I STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WINNER [inaudible]
BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE.
ARCHULETA.
BATES [inaudible]
NO.
MORE LOCK.
AYE AYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS SIX
THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SIXTY SENATOR DOT CENTER DOT IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL TWO THIRTY FIVE A
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING.
WELCOME BACK CENTER DOT THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS AS
B. TWO THIRTY FIVE IS A DISTRICT
BILL THAT ALLOWS A CITY AND
COUNTY OF NAPA TO EXPEDITE THE
PRODUCTION.
OF CRITICALLY NEEDED HOUSING
UNITS INCLUDING DEED RESTRICTED
UNITS FOR VERY LOW LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THE BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE THE
CITY AND COUNTY TO REACH A
MUTUALLY ACCEPTABLE AGREEMENT TO
ALLOW ONE OF THOSE JURISDICTIONS
TO REPORT ON ITS ANNUAL HOUSING
PRODUCTION.
REPORT -- TO EIGHT CD -- REPORT
THOSE THE BILL REPORT THOSE
ENTITLEMENTS BUILDING PERMITS
CERTIFICATES OF OCCUPANCY ISSUED
BY THE OTHER JURISDICTION FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT HOUSING IF
CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
ALL OF THIS OF COURSE WAS WORKED
OUT THROUGH A MULTI PHASE
DEVELOPMENT AGREEMENT ACTUALLY
WHEN I WAS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR --
IN NAPA COUNTY HOWEVER AFTER
EVALUATING CURRENT MARKET
CONDITIONS IN INFRASTRUCTURE
SCENARIOS THE DEVELOPER
DETERMINED TO THE PROJECT CANNOT
MOVE FORWARD WITHOUT MOVING SOME
OF THE HOUSING. TO THE FIRST
PHASE OF THE DEVELOPMENT ON THE
LAND ALREADY IN X. TO THE CITY.
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH OUTSIDE
THIS LEGISLATION THE COUNTY HAS
NO LEGAL MECHANISM THE ISSUE
BUILDING PERMITS OR OBTAIN
CREDITS TOWARDS MEETING ITS
CURRENT ARE A GENTE.
DESPITE NAPA BY BEING THE
CENTERPIECE OF THE COUNTIES
CURRENT HOUSING ELEMENT.
SB TWO THIRTY FIVE WILL ENSURE
THAT THIS CRITICAL HOUSING
PROJECT IS ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITHOUT PENALIZING THE COUNTY
FOR WORKING COLLABORATIVELY ON
THIS IMPORTANT PROJECT.
THIS BILL IS RECEIVE UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IN COMMITTEE AND THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
MEMBERS DO WE HAVE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN.
NINE IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
USE UTILIZING OR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON THIS ITEM.
WE DO HAVE AN OBJECTION MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
HI BATES.
BY BILL BY PORGES [inaudible]
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
BY CHIANG.
I DODD.
EITHER ALTHOUGH.
AYE GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO HI -- TADO.
I JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
HI LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
[inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY NUMBER.
BOB I COUNTY I WINNER.
HI WILK.
BY.
IT'S A SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE
ARCHULETA.
MCGUIRE HI HI MORE LUCK.
ICE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE LIKE
TO BE ABLE TO JUMP BACK TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR SENATOR
DODD.
YES -- MISTER PRESIDENT FOR
PURPOSES OF INTRODUCTION PLEASE
PROCEED.
YOU WE HAVE TODAY CASA GRANDE
HIGH SCHOOL FOR A BIT IN
PETALUMA IN THE HOUSE THERE
UPSTAIRS THESE ARE HIGH SCHOOL
SENIORS THAT ARE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL TODAY WITH THEIR SOCIAL
STUDIES TEACHER LISA CAME WHEN
YOU JOIN ME IN WELCOMING THEM.
CRAZY GERMAN THAT'S WELCOME THE
CASA GRANDE GOD CHOSE TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER DODD.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD.
THE WITH HER FILE.
LOOKING FOR FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
CENTER NIELSEN HE PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM SIXTY TWO SENATOR PAN YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT PASS ON FILE.
ITEM SIXTY THREE SENATOR BELL
PASS ON FILE.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTY FOUR CENTER
RUBIO.
CENTER RUBIO IS READY TO GO.
TELL ME PLEASE READ SENATE BILL
THREE SIXTEEN BY SENATOR RUBIO
AN ACT RELATING TO PEOPLE IN
STUDENT SAFETY.
MORE SORRY BROWN ONE A PASS ON
FILE AND BAD APOLOGIES.
THE BEST IS YET TO COME ON ITEM.
SIXTY FOUR WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
ON ITEM SIXTY FIVE CENTER
BRADFORD CENTER BRADFORD IS
READY TO GO.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY TWO BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT RELATING
TO HEALTH FACILITIES THE WELCOME
CENTER BRADFORD TO THE FLOOR SIR
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MISTER PRESIDENT SB. THREE TWO
TWO PROTECTION ARSES AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE WORKERS ABILITY TO
SPEAK PRIVATELY WITH STATE
INSPECTORS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DURING INSPECTION.
CURRENTLY THAT -- ABILITY ONLY
EXISTS -- IN THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR COAL DEALING WITH CAL OSHA.
AND HOWEVER -- THE TO LAW
AFFORDING FACILITIES STAFF THE
SAME RIGHT TO SPEAK PROBABLY
WOULD INSPECTOR DORN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH -- EXTRACTION ONE EXPECTS
UNITED STATES SO IT PROVIDES THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY THAT -- CAL
OSHA PROVIDES THESE POLICIES ARE
SIMPLY CONTRADICTORY AND CALLS
ON THE SYRIAN DANGERS CONFUSION
DURING THE STATE RUN INSPECTION.
OF THE SAME WORKPLACE -- SB
THIRTY TO GET CLARITY TO THIS
ISSUES AND BRINGS PARITY TO LAW
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I SIMPLY I
SAW VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS
WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
HEARING SEEN NINE MISTER
SECRETARY.
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA ATKINS.
HI BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THE RISE OF HI GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TOTAL [inaudible]
I JACKSON.
I JONES.
HI LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE I MITCHELL.
BY MONEY I'M MORE LOCK.
MORALE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
[inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
CASKEY.
I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI.
MISTER SECRETARY WE LIKE TO CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE
ARCHULETA.
BURGESS.
HI [inaudible]
MORE LUCK.
AYE AYES THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM.
SIXTY SIX CENTER HERTZBERG IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
IT'S A CENTER HERTZBERG SHOW
TODAY MORE COWBELL.
THE IT'S IT.
IS A SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTRICITY MR
MAJORITY LEADER.
IN THE DIFFICULT TIMES OF TWO
THOUSAND ONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTRICITY CRISIS.
THIS LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR
CREATED THE RESOURCE ADEQUACY
PROGRAM AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION.
THE PURPOSE OF RESOURCE ADEQUACY
THEN AND NOW WAS TO BUILD AND
RETAIN POWER PLANTS SO THAT WE
NEVER HAD A POWER SHORTAGE AGAIN.
HOWEVER OUR RETAIL ELECTRICITY A
MARKET PLACE IS FACING ENORMOUS
CHANGES WE HAVE SEATED HERE
ALMOST ON A DAILY BASIS OVER THE
LAST NUMBER OF YEARS IN THIS
LEGISLATURE.
AND SO HAS OUR REGULATORY SYSTEM
SUCH A EXPERIENCE SIMILAR BUT
CHANGES.
SO.
ON OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS.
SEVERAL LOCAL AREAS HAVE BEEN
STRUGGLING TO HAVE SUFFICIENT
RESOURCES UNDER CONTRACT
RESULTING IN EXPENSIVE THE LAST
MINUTE POWER PROCUREMENT
RESOURCE ADEQUACY REQUIRES THAT.
EVERYONE.
UP PLAY THEIR PART IN THE
REGULAR IN THE REGULATORY
PROGRAM OF ELECTRICAL RELY
ABILITY. ONE SOLUTION IDENTIFIED
BY A NUMBER OF STAKEHOLDERS IS
TO CONSIDER ESTABLISHING WHAT
WAS KNOWN AS A CENTRAL
PROCUREMENT ENTITY SUCH ENTITY
WOULD COVER GAPS IN LONG TERM
CONTRACTING IS TO ENSURE ACCESS.
TO AFFORDABLE CAPITAL IN
CONTRACTS ACROSS ALL MARKET
PLAYERS WHETHER CCA'S DIRECT
ACCESS OR CUSTOMERS OF LOTS OF
BEHIND THE METER RESOURCES.
A CENTRAL BUYER IS HISTORICALLY
PROVEN APPROACH FOUND OTHER
STATES TO COORDINATE COST
EFFECTIVE ELECTRICAL PROCUREMENT.
SB FIFTY PUTS THIS OPTION ON THE
TABLE AND WILL HELP US MEET OUR
OTHER STATE WIDE ENVIRONMENTAL
GOALS SINCE SOME OF THE
RESOURCES WE NEED -- SO LARGE NO
SINGLE ENTITY CAN CONTRACT FOR
THEM THE BILL WILL PROTECT RATE
PAYERS THROUGH ECONOMIES OF
SCALE AND BY AVOIDING EXPENSIVE
NON MARKET BASED BACKSTOP
PROCUREMENT.
ARE RESPECTIVELY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATORS SWEET DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
HEARING SEE NINE SENATORS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION.
EYES THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO CONTINUE
WORKING THE FILE.
SENATOR WILL BE PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE MEMBERS ARE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT
SENATOR RUBIO.
RUBIO IS READY TO GO.
MR SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTEEN BY
SENATOR RUBIO AN ACT RELATING TO
THE SAN GABRIEL WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY.
GOOD MORNING MAN IT IS DEL PASS
ON FILE SORRY.
NO WORRIES THOUGH GOOD.
MEMBERS ARE NOW GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO ITEM.
SIXTY NINE CENTER MONEY IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR MONNING AN ACT
RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR MONEY GOOD
MORNING -- MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AS THE NUMBER OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN FOOD IN SECURITY
CONTINUES TO RISE.
THE CSU AND YOU SEE HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO PROVIDE
PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS WITH
ACCURATE ESTIMATES FOR THE COST
OF ATTENDING THEIR SCHOOLS.
AND THE METHODOLOGY THEY USE TO
DETERMINE THOSE ESTIMATES.
SENATE BILL FOUR SIXTY SEVEN
REQUIRES THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND REQUESTS THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. TO
PLACE ON THEIR WEBSITES THE
CONFERENCE OF COST OF ATTENDANCE
INCLUDING THE CURRENT COST OF AN
OFF CAMPUS TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT
IN A SINGLE BEDROOM IN A PRIVATE
HOME FOR PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS.
IN ADDITION TO SOME OTHER
DETAILED COSTS THIS BILL
EMPOWERS PROSPECTIVE STUDENTS TO
MAKE FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE
DECISIONS WHEN REVIEWING A
PERSPECTIVE SEE ISSUE OR YOU SEE.
THIS IS SUPPORTED BROUGHT TO US
BY CSU STUDENTS MEMBERS ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR SENATOR
SWEET DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO UTILIZING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION NICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WOULD LIKE TO ADVANCED
ITEM SEVENTY SENATOR BRADFORD IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FOR NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AND ACT REALLY
IN ENERGY.
WELCOME BACK CENTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AS
BEFORE NINE SEVEN IS A STREET
FOR MEASURED SIMPLY REQUIRES.
THE CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO COME BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE FOR ANNUAL
HEARING SIMILAR TO WHAT IS A
REQUIREMENT FROM THE P. YOU SEE
AND OTHER AGENCIES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS
IS INTERNET DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE.
SENATORS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
UTILIZING OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
HEARING SEE NO OBJECTION NICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES.
WERE DANCING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY ONE CENTER OF BURGERS
RATE TO GO MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE OH FIVE BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND ACTUALLY TO
ELECTIONS A DECLINING THERE'S
THE RUSTIC FACT IMMEDIATELY.
CENTER I'M BURKE THE FLOORS YOUR
SIR THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I'VE RECENTLY BEEN
INFORMED THAN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY THERE'LL BE A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
ALL OVER THE UNITED STATES
INCLUDING HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'VE ALSO BEEN INFORMED THAT THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AT HIS OR HER
OWN DISCRETION COULD DECIDE.
WHAT CANDIDATES WILL APPEAR AS
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES ON THE
BALLOT IT IS CURRENTLY
SUBJECTIVE WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS THIS BILL ADD SOME OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA A VERY LOW BAR? FOR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES TO
APPEAR ON THE BALLOT.
BOB THIS VERY LOW BAR DOES
REQUIRE THEM TO ACTUALLY FOR
EXAMPLE BE A RECOGNIZE CANDIDATE
BY EITHER BEING IN -- IT INDOORS
CAM A BY **** ANOTHER STATE.
OR BY HAVING A CERTAIN
PERCENTAGE OF POLLING.
OR FOR EXAMPLE -- BY OPENING A
CAMPAIGN OFFICE HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS A
SIMPLE MEASURE THAT SIMPLY
APPLIES OBJECTIVE CRITERIA TO
APPEARING ON THE PRESIDENTIAL
BALLOT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH AS
TO SENATOR MEMBERS TO A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR WE DO CENTER ALLEN GOOD
MORNING.
WELL I WANT -- TO MEMBERS I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FOR RAISING
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE I THINK IT
REALLY DOES -- BRING UP THE
EXTRAORDINARY SUBJECTIVITY THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS IN LAW WITH
REGARD TO THE PLACEMENT.
OF PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES ON
THE BALLOT.
I WILL SAY THAT -- I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT HIS WORK YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S WE'RE GETTING INTO
THIS AREA OF LAW THAT WERE FAIR.
AND ONE OF THE QUESTIONS -- THE
THAT I'VE BEEN TALKING THE
CENTRAL BUT ABOUT IS -- REMEMBER
THIS IS THE ONLY TIME NOW WHEN
CALIFORNIANS CAN ACTUALLY VOTE
AND WILL ACTUALLY VOTE IN A
CLOSE PRIMARY EVERY OTHER --
WE'VE UPENDED PRIMARIES WITH THE
TOP TWO SYSTEM.
BUT JUST FOR THE PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY ONLY -- THE THE THOSE
ARE CLOSE PRIMARIES.
NOW FOR THE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A
YOU KNOW IT IT DID PRETTY CLEAR
WHAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING THERE
BIG NATIONAL CAMPAIGNS BUT
REMEMBER OUR OUR FRIENDS FROM
THE GREEN.
OF PEACE AND FREEDOM LIBERTARIAN
PARTIES ARE ALSO SELECTING THEIR
PRESIDENTIAL NOMINEES AT THE
SAME TIME.
AND I THINK THAT THE COURT
CONCERNED TO TO NEEDS TO BE HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE FAIR
TO THEM AS THEY'RE GOING TO THE
PROCESS SELECTING THEIR NOMINEES.
SO ARE SO YOU KNOW IN THE IN THE
BILL FOR EXAMPLE THERE'S A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE CANDIDATE
HAS TO HAVE.
AT LEAST ONE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN OFFICE IN CALIFORNIA I
TO BE CONSIDERED UNDER THE UNDER
UNDER THESE RULES AS I JUST
REVIEW OF WITH THE PERMISSION OF
THE OF THE CHAIR I'D LOVE.
TO ASK A QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
SONORA BURKE WOULD YOU ACCEPT A
QUESTION FROM CENTER ALLEN I'D
BE HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE QUESTION
FROM SEVERAL OKAY AROUND CAN YOU
PLEASE FOR C..
SO.
YOU AND I TALKED ABOUT ON ON
PAGE THREE FOR EXAMPLE THE BILL
TALKS ABOUT -- ABOUT HOW
CANDIDATE IN ORDER TO BE PLACED
ON THE BALLOT BY THE SECRETARY
OF STATE UNDER THIS BILL THEY
WOULD HAVE TO HAVE.
AT LEAST ONE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN OFFICE IN CALIFORNIA IS
IT YOUR INTENT THAT THEY COULD
UTILIZE -- THE PARTY THEIR
PARTIES CAN'T YOU KNOW --
OFFICES. FOR THE PURPOSES OF
THIS OF THIS LANGUAGE ON ON PAGE
THREE THIS IS SECTION THE ONE HE
WON I WOULD THAT BE SUFFICIENT
UNDER YOUR UNDER YOUR VISION FOR
THIS BILL -- TO MEET THE
CRITERIA FOR AT LEAST ONE
PRESENTS A CAMPING OUT IN
CALIFORNIA SO FOR EXAMPLE LET'S
SAY MINOR PARTY CANDIDATE
DESIGNATED HIS OR HER.
PARTY HEADQUARTERS AS THEIR
HEADQUARTERS AS WELL THAT WOULD
BE SUFFICIENT.
OKAY -- I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VERY HELPFUL BECAUSE REMEMBER
YOU'RE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
CAMPAIGNS THAT ARE MUCH SMALLER
THAN THE THAN THE BIG NATIONAL
CAMPAIGNS.
THAT ARE PARTIES -- HALF OKAY
THAT'S ONE THING -- I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE DOING SOME ADDITIONAL
WORK I KNOW YOU GOT SOME
AMENDMENTS AYE AYE I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS I WILL ALSO.
YOU YOU TOLD ME THAT -- UNDER
CURRENT LAW.
ANOTHER WAY THAT THAT THAT
CANDIDATES COULD GET ON TO THE
BALLOT.
ASIDE FROM THIS PROCESS WOULD BE
TO COLLECT SIGNATURES EQUIVALENT
21% OF THE PARTY MEMBERSHIP IN
THE STATE WHICH I THINK FOR
GREEN OR PIECE OF FREEDOM
LIBERTARIANS IS LESS THAN A
THOUSAND SIGNATURES SO THAT THAT
WOULD BE ANOTHER AVENUE.
FOR PEOPLE TO GET ON THE BALLOT
BUT I I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD WE'RE ALL PART OF THE
TWO BIG PARTIES AND AND WE'RE
PROUD OF OUR PARTIES BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE BEING FAIR.
TO SOME OF THE SMALLER PARTIES
AS WELL AND I I JUST WANT TO SAY
I APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS AN
OPENNESS TO TO WORK WITH -- WITH
EVERYONE ON THIS.
I CAN'T.
WAIT I I'M SORRY CENTER BURKE
SIT AROUND SAID IN A FORM OF A
QUESTION THAT YOU'D LIKE THAT
SENATOR TO BE ABLE TO DRESS YES
IT IS THANK YOU SO MUCH AND THEN
CENTER NUMBER -- THAT'S IF YOU
DON'T MIND LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE
ANYONE ELSE IN YOU CAN COVER
THAT YOU'RE CLOSE IF WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OF THAT WORKS FOR FOLKS.
MEMBERS ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL.
COMMENTS ARE DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
WE DO SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY PLEASE.
PLEASE SAY GIVE US. TWENTY
SECONDS.
THE OUR ANALYSIS DOESN'T
INDICATE ANYTHING ABOUT
AMENDMENTS.
AND I DON'T THINK THE THE
PRISONER SAID ANYTHING ABOUT
AMENDMENTS IN HIS OPENING.
SO I'M JUST WONDERING -- HOW WE
HAVE A BILL ON THE FLOOR THAT'S
HAS AMENDMENTS?
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER JONES.
BEFORE WE EVER SEE GIVE US
TWENTY SECONDS WE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
COR INTERESSES SECTOR THE SENATE
THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS PENDING.
THE LAST AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
TAKEN IN THIS BILL WERE TAKEN ON
MARCH TWENTY FIFTH THERE ARE NO
WHEN THEY MEAN SPENDING ON THE
FLOOR TODAY.
I BELIEVE SENATOR ALLEN WAS
SIMPLY ASKING THE QUESTION BUT
THERE ARE NO AMENDMENTS PENDING
ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
CENTER JONES MISTER PRESIDENT
THANK YOU QUESTION FOR THE
AUTHOR.
CENTER NUMBER WILL YOU ACCEPT A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR JONES A
MOST ASSUREDLY THINNER JONES CAN
YOU PLEASE PROCEED YES THANK YOU
COULD YOU PLEASE.
THIS -- ANSWER TO THE QUESTION
REGARDING AMENDMENTS ARE YOU.
PLANNING ON TAKING AMENDMENTS IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND IF SO CAN YOU
ADDRESS THOSE TODAY AND GIVE US
AN IDEA OF WHAT WE'RE EXPECTING
THIS PRODUCT TO LOOK LIKE WHEN
IT COMES BACK THANK YOU -- YES
THANK YOU OF FOR THE IMPORTANT
QUESTION IT AND MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA IS CORRECT HE
AND I HAD DISCUSSED --
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
ANTICIPATED IN THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD ACTUALLY LOWER THE BAR IN
TERMS OF THE SORT OF THE THE
FIVE CRITERIA ORIGINALLY IT SAYS
YOU MUST BE TWO OF THE FIVE THE
INTENDED AMENDMENT WOULD MEAN
THAT YOU'D ONLY NEED TO BE ONE
OF THOSE FIVE CRITERIA -- IN IN
MY COLLEAGUE IS CORRECT.
ALSO CALLER FROM CINEMA IS
CORRECT THAT FOR EXAMPLE IF
SOMEONE FOR WHATEVER REASON
CAN'T MEET.
THOSE RELATIVELY LOWER A LOWER
THRESHOLD THEY ALSO COLLECT
SIGNATURES AND FOR THE PEACE AND
FREEDOM PARTY WOULD BE SEVEN
SIXTY EIGHT SIGNATURES FOR THE
NEXT -- PRESIDENTIAL PRIMARY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER UMBERG
CENTER JONES IN YOUR OWN TIME
WOULD YOU LIKE TO INCLUDE
COMMENTS OR DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER
QUESTION FOR THE GOOD CENTER NOT
OVER AT MY AT MY OWN TIME THANK
YOU PLEASE FOR SIDE.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT --
AND TO THE PRESENTER I WAS
PREPARED TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY BUT SINCE IT SOUNDS LIKE
IT'S NOT.
FULLY DEVELOPED I'M GONNA LAY
OFF TODAY AND ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO EITHER VOTE NO OR
LAY OFF UNTIL WE HAVE A FINAL
PRODUCT THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MUCH ENERGY OWNS. TO THIS BILL.
YEAH MEMBERS ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CENTER ALLEN PLEASE FOR SEE YEAH
I I JUST -- SINCE I WAS GOING TO
OPEN THE PANDORA'S BOX HERE I I
WOULD ENCOURAGE MY MY DEAR
COLLEAGUE TO TO RECONSIDER HIS
OPPOSITION -- THE REASON BEING
IF IT DID THE THE THE THE BILL
IS ESSENTIALLY GOING TO STAY THE
SAME.
LITERALLY ALL THEY WOULD BE
DOING WOULD BE MAKE IT EASIER
FOR BALLOT ACCESS RIGHT NOW IT'S
A BIT OF A WILD WEST THE
SECRETARY STATE IS GIVEN A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF DISCRETION.
AS TO WHO GETS ON THE BALLOT AND
IN FACT WITH THE SECTOR STATE ON
THE AUTHOR TRYING TO DO IS
PROVIDE FOR MORE CLARITY AND
MORE -- MORE FAIRNESS THAT'S
RIGHT IN BLACK AND WHITE FOR
FOLKS TO KNOW HOW TO GET ON TO
THE BALLOT OR NOT.
THE ONLY CHANGE IT HE'S
ANTICIPATING IT AS YOU HEARD WAS
TO GO FROM HAVING TO BE TO THE
CRITERIA DOWN TO ONE OF THE
CRITERIA SO IT'S A VERY
TRANSPARENT CHANGE THAT REALLY
DOESN'T CHANGE THE SUBS OF THE
BILL ALL IT DOES.
IS MAKE IT.
MAKE IT A LITTLE EASIER FOR
CANDIDATES TO GET ON THE BALLOT
IN A CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT WAY
SO I I WITH RESPECT AYE AYE THE
THE THE CHEESY HE'S ANTICIPATING
HE JUST ARTICULATED IS NOT.
SUBSTANTIVE TO SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT A FULLY BATES BILL I JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE AN
OPEN DISCUSSION.
ABOUT THE CORE PRINCIPLE THAT
WILL BE GUARDED BY THIS BILL
WHICH IS WHICH IS ACCESS CLARITY
AND FAIRNESS FOR ALL
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES OF OF OF
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF RIGOR -- FROM
ALL THE PARTIES INCLUDING THE
VERY SMALL ONES.
AND WITH THAT I DO ENCOURAGE
WITHIN WITH THE COMMITTEES MADE
I REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO
TO CONSIDER ARE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER ALLEN
MEMBERS.
WE'RE STILL HAVING DEBATE AND
DISCUSSION ON THE FLOOR WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO SENATOR
JONES IN SENATOR BATES CENTER
JONES THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AT AND I AGREE IN TRUSTS -- THE
PRIOR PRISONER AND THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL I JUST BELIEVE IT SETS
A SET A BAD PRECEDENT FOR THE
SENATE TO BE PASSING BILLS OVER
TO THE ASSEMBLY.
AND TRUST THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
COME BACK IN THE SAME MANNER
THAT WE THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
COME BACK AND AGAIN -- HOLD TO
MY POSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER JONES.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR BATES.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT A
QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR I MIGHT.
FEDERAL BURKE WOULD YOU ACCEPT A
QUESTION FROM SENATOR BATES.
CERTAINLY CENTER BASED CAN YOU
PLEASE PROCEED -- ARE IS
CALIFORNIA UNIQUE AND GIVING
SUCH WIDE DISCRETION TO OUR
SECRETARY OF STATE IN
DETERMINING WHO MIGHT BE ON A
PRESIDENTIAL BALLOT.
THANK YOU SERVICE I DON'T KNOW
THE ANSWER THAT QUESTION -- BUT
I DO KNOW IS THAT.
CURRENTLY BECAUSE THE CRITERIA
IS NOT OBJECTIVE IT IS
SUBJECTIVE THAT THEORETICALLY
THE SECRETARY OF STATE COULD
DECIDE THAT THAT THE REPUBLICAN.
NOMINEE FOR THE REPUBLICAN WHO
IS MOST PROMIENT THE POLLS
MIGHT NOT SHOW UP ON THE BALLOT
NOW OF COURSE THAT PERSON WOULD
SUE AND AND PROBABLY END UP
BEING ON THE BALLOT BECAUSE THIS.
CURRENT STANDARD IS RECOGNIZABLE
THAT'S THE CURRENT STANDARD SO
THIS SIMPLY CREATES OBJECTIVE
CRITERIA.
ALSO WITH RESPECT TO ANY MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY BILL CERTAINLY
COME BACK TO THE SENATE.
WE'LL ALL HAVE A CHANCE BOTH IN
COMMITTEE AND ON THE FLOOR TO
MAKE A DECISION AS TO WHETHER
THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE ACCEPTABLE
OR NOT SO IT IS NOT AS THOUGH.
THIS IS NOT GONNA BE SEEN AGAIN
SHOULD THERE BE AN AMENDMENT.
THANK YOU ON MY OWN TIME I IN
YOUR OWN TIME THAT -- THE THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM ORANGE COUNTY
IS PROCEEDING AND I THINK A VERY
DELIBERATE WAY ON IT IS OF
CONCERN THAT THE SECRETARY OF
STATE WOULD HAVE THAT KIND OF
DISCRETION THAT ACTUALLY COULD.
I IN FACT -- DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST A POTENTIAL CANDIDATE
BECAUSE OF THE SUBJECTIVE
REASONS SO WITHOUT I FEEL
SUPPORTIVE BUT I THINK I WILL
LAY OFF UNTIL IT RETURNS --
EUNICE FINAL FORM BUT I THINK
YOU ARE HITTING THE ENDING IN A
GOOD DIRECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER BATES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE.
WOULD LIKE ME TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
CENTER AMBERG PLEASE CLOSE AND
IF THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
ITEMS THAT YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE.
TO ADDRESS IN SEVEN ROUNDS
ORIGINAL QUESTION THE FLOOR IS
YOURS FOR THE CLOSER.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS -- THAT THE SYSTEM THAT
WE HAVE NOW AND IT IS CRAZY IN A
CREDIT TO THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO ASK US TO PROVIDE SOME
OBJECTIVE CRITERIA. TO SIMPLY
SAY NO TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT
WE'RE GONNA LEAVE IT IS STATUS
QUO WE'RE NOT GOING TO MOVE
FORWARD.
IS.
TECHNICALLY NOT OF WHAT WE
SHOULD DO IS WE SHOULD PASS THIS
BILL -- IF THERE'S ANY ISSUE
THAT SHOULD ARISE IT SHOULD
CAUSE ANY CONSTERNATION IT WILL
COME BACK.
IN AT THAT POINT IN TIME IF THE
MINORITY PARTY DECIDES THAT THEY
WANT TO RAISE THE BAR.
WE CAN HAVE THAT CONVERSATION
BUT FOR NOW AND FOR TODAY I
THINK WE SHOULD.
ED OBJECTIVE CRITERIA AND ARE
TONIGHT BOTH.
THANK YOU MISTER SENATOR MEMBERS
A REMINDER.
THE LAST TIME THIS BILL RECEIVED
AMENDMENTS WAS MARCH TWENTY
FIFTH.
THE BILL THAT'S IN FRONT OF THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
ACTION ON MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
HI.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BILL.
I WERE JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
HI GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
I JACKSON [inaudible]
BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE.
HI MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I AM FIVE WHAT COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
BY.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONCE
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA BATES [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
JONES.
MORE LOCK BY [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI.
SENATORS FIVE THIRTY THREE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY.
AYE AYES THIRTY THREE NO ZERO ON
THE MEASURE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
IN OUR FILE THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO CENTER JONES IS
PREPARED TO PRESENT MISTER
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTEEN BY
SENATOR JONES AND ACRYLATES
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES HE WALKS
WELCOME CENTER JONES BACK TO THE
FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT THE
TIMING OF MY PRESENTATION MIGHT
BE UNFORTUNATE BUT I'M CERTAINLY
HOPING I'VE GOT ALL MY DUCKS IN
A ROW IS A PRISON TODAY.
SB.
SEVEN ONE SEVEN HOPEFULLY IS A
PRETTY SIMPLE BILL.
CURRENT LAW OFFERS A TIGHT HOUSE
EXEMPTION TO ALCOHOL
MANUFACTURERS THAT ALLOWS THEM
TO BUY ADVERTISING SPACE IS
STADIUMS.
AND SPORTS ARENAS SB SEVEN ONE
SEVEN CODIFIES EXISTING PRACTICE
BY EXPLICITLY INCLUDING CRAFT
DISTILLERS IN THIS EXEMPTION.
I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER JONES.
MEMBERS WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
FOCUS ON THOSE IN DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE WE LIKE TO BE A START
WITH.
DINNER STONE AND THEN CENTER
BOARD JUST CENTER STONE THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SIR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT I
HAVE A NUMBER OF CRAFT
DISTILLERS IN IN MY DISTRICT AND
I'D LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE.
SENATOR JONES WILL YOU ACCEPT
THE QUESTION FROM SENATOR STONE
I CERTAINLY WILL.
CENTER STONE CAN YOU PLEASE FOR
SCIENCE TEAM CALLING NORTH OF
MICE MY OWN DISTRICT A MY FRIEND
MY SENATOR FROM A SAN DIEGO DO
SOLEMNLY SWEAR.
THAT YOU HAVE NOT TAKEN ANY
AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL OR PLAN
TO TAKE ANY MEMBERS IN THIS BILL
AS IT PROCEEDS TO THE ASSEMBLY
SHOULD WE GRANT YOU APPROVAL FOR
THIS BILL TODAY HERE IN THE
ESTEEM SENATE.
UNDER THE COLLEGIALITY RULES
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE HOUSE I
APPRECIATE CENTER JONES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO RESPOND PLEASE
MISTER PRESIDENT I CAN ANSWER
FOR MYSELF THAT I DO AGREE WITH
THAT BUT I CAN'T ANSWER FOR THE
ASSEMBLY WHO KNOWS WHAT THEY'RE
GONNA DO.
IT OR GO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER SO WE
LIKE TO KEEP IT OPERATE HERE IN
THE SENATE SO.
WE'RE GONNA TURN THE FLOOR OVER
TO CENTER BORCHERS.
I WOULD JUST TO LEND MY SUPPORT --
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM -- FROM --
SAN DIEGO I THINK THIS IS A
MERITORIOUS BILL.
IN ITS EXISTING FORM AND WOULD
ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER SENATOR
MEMBERS ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR WE LIKE TO LOOK AT LAST
CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER JONES
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE PLEASE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASK DR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL WE DO
HAVE AN OBJECTION [inaudible]
HELLO KITTY.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CARRIER OF CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
JURADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
DROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL [inaudible]
HUESO -- TALA [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONEY [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROCK [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
SKINNER [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK [inaudible]
NO.
CENTER JACKSON MOVES THE CALL.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE.
I DON'T NEVER SENT ME TO REMAIN
ON CALL WE'RE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY THREE SENATOR PANY
PREPARED TO PRISON I DID.
SEVENTY THREE YES I BY -- YEP.
APPROACH HIM I THINK EVERYTHING
IS ON ICE AT THE MOMENT SO -- OR
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTY FOUR PASS ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR STERN IF
YOU DARE.
BASS ON FILE MEMBERS ITEM
SEVENTY SIX IS NOT ELIGIBLE
ITEMS SEVENTY SEVEN PASS ON FILE
ITEM SEVENTY EIGHT IS NOT
ELIGIBLE.
ITEMS SEVENTY NINE SENATOR PAN.
PASS ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY CENTER
LEYVA.
PASS ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY ONE
SENATOR RUBIO.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
SEN RUBIO IS PREPARED TO PRESENT
MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
READ.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
THIRTY NINE BY SENATOR RUBIO
RELATIVE TO SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH DENIM DAY
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS OF THE GET HAVE
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION PLEASE.
CENTER RUBIO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT S.
C. R. THIRTY NINE WHICH
PROCLAIMS APRIL TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN AT SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH.
AND DESIGNATES APRIL TWENTY SIX
TWENTY NINETEEN AS DOWN I'M DAY
CELEBRATING ITS TWENTIETH
ANNIVERSARY.
THE NATIONAL INTIMATE PARTNER
AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE SURVEY
REPORTS THAT THERE ARE OVER
TWENTY TWO MILLION SUPER.
DRIVERS OF RAID WITH TWO MILLION
OF THOSE SURVIVING SURVIVORS
LIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT THE
ITALIAN SUPREME COURT OVERTURNED
THE CONVICTION OF A MAN WHO
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD WOMAN BECAUSE SHE WAS
WEARING JEANS.
IN RAGE BY THE COURT'S DECISION
WITHOUT.
I HESITATION THE WOMEN IN THE
ITALIAN PARLIAMENT LAUNCHED.
I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE HAVE QUITE A FEW SIDE
CONVERSATIONS ON THE FLOOR.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PRESENTATION.
WE'D LIKE TO GET A FOCUS ON THE
PRESENTATION BY CENTER RUBIO
NEVER GONNA HAVE OTHER SENATORS
STANDING TO BE ABLE TO JOIN WITH
THE SENATOR CENTER RUBIO CAN YOU
PLEASE PROCEED I APOLOGIZE BUT
INTERRUPTING.
THANK YOU.
ENRAGED BY THE COURT'S DECISION
WITH WITHIN HOURS WOMEN IN THE
ITALIAN PARLIAMENT LAUNCHED INTO
IMMEDIATE ACTION IN PROTEST OF
BY WEARING JEANS TO WORK.
NATIONS IN STATES THROUGHOUT THE
WORLD HAVE FOLLOWED THE LEAD OF
THE ITALIAN PARLIAMENT BY
DESIGNATING THEIR OWN DENIM DATE
TO RAISE PUBLIC AWARENESS ABOUT
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THIS RESOLUTION ENCOURAGES ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO WEAR JEANS ¡N
DENIM DATE WHICH HELPS
COMMUNICATE THE MESSAGE THAT
THERE IS NO EXCUSE.
AND EVER AN INVITATION TO COMMIT
RAPE JUST BECAUSE YOU WEAR JEANS.
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT IMPACTS
PEOPLE OF ALL RACIAL CULTURAL
AND ECONOMIC BACKGROUNDS HARMFUL
ATTITUDES ABOUT RAPE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULTS ALLOW THESE CRIMES TO
PROCESS. FOR SURVIVORS TO BE RE
VICTIMIZE THE VICTIM BLAMING
ATTITUDES DENIM DAYS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO WEAR
JEANS FOR A PURPOSE TO SUPPORT
SURVIVORS.
AND EDUCATE THEMSELVES ABOUT THE
DIFFERENT FORMS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF THOSE WHO WORE JEANS
YESTERDAY ALL OF THE VISITORS
THEY CAME TO THE CAPITOL TO JOIN
US AT THE RALLY.
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND ALL OF US
TO CALL WORE OUR CAN.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR LISTENING AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO CENTER
LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT I RISE AS A CHAIR THAT
WAS CAUCUS I RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION I
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD.
SOME OF YOU HAVE PROBABLY HEARD
ME SAY ONE OF THE THINGS I LOVE
ABOUT THIS JOB IS YOU GET HERE
AND YOU YOU GET TO FIX PROBLEMS.
AND WHEN I FIRST HEARD THIS
STORY IT WAS SHOCKING TO ME THAT
A JUDGE WOULD ACTUALLY RULED
THAT IT WAS THE WOMAN'S FAULT
BECAUSE HER JEANS WERE TIGHT AND
SHE MUST HAVE HELPED THE RAPIST.
TAKE THEM OFF SO IT'S JUST
SHOCKING -- WHEN MANY OF YOU ON
THIS FLOOR VOTED TO ELIMINATE
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATION -- ON
RAPE I THANK YOU FOR THAT AND IF
WE ALL STICK TOGETHER AND WE ALL
WORK TOGETHER MAYBE ONE DAY WE
WILL FINALLY END RATE.
AND MAYBE ONE DAY WOMEN WILL BE
RESPECTED AS THEY SHOULD BE SO
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO AND
THANK YOU ALL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SENATOR ALSO
CHAIR THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS WE'D
LIKE TO BETTER TURNED OVER TO
SENATOR JACKSON.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CENTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I AM.
I LOOK BACK AT MY EARLY CAREER
WHICH FOR SOME WAS A LONG LONG
TIME AGO AND THEY PROBABLY
WEREN'T EVEN ALIVE YET -- AS A
DEPUTY DA.
BACK TRUST.
A FEW DECADES AGO.
A MAN COULD NOT RAPE HIS WIFE.
THE LAW SPECIFICALLY SAID RAPE
IS A CRIME COMMITTED AGAINST
SOMEONE OTHER THAN YOUR WIFE.
SO IT HASN'T BEEN THAT LONG.
SINCE WE HAVE RECOGNIZED HOW
SIGNIFICANT AND SERIOUS A CRIME
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
OUR IT IS THESE ARE CRIMES THAT
ARE DESIGNED TO HUMILIATE. TO
DEGRADE TWO SUBORDINATE TO
SUBJUGATE WOMEN.
AND SO I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION BUT ALSO TO REMIND.
OUR COLLEAGUES THAT.
THE ATTITUDES ABOUT RAPE.
HAVE CHANGED BUT NOT QUITE AS
QUICKLY AS WE WOULD HOPE.
AND SO WE HAVE TO ALSO CONSIDER
THE FACT THAT.
RAPE AND SEXUAL ASSAULT ARE
CRIMES.
THAT A REPORTED ONLY ABOUT 23%
OF THE TIME.
WHY BECAUSE WOMEN ARE AFRAID OF
BEING ACCUSED AGAIN THE FAULT
LAY WITH THE WOMAN WHO WAS
WEARING BLUE JEANS?
WE NOW HAVE MOVEMENT MOVEMENTS
ARE OF HEAD MOVEMENTS LIKE TAKE
BACK THE NIGHT.
BECAUSE WOMEN ARE AFRAID OFTEN
TO GO OUT IN THE EVENING AND IF
THEY ARE IF THEY DO AND THEY
WERE ASSAULTED.
IT IS THEIR FAULT.
AND SO WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE IT
AS MUCH AS WE SYMBOLICALLY WEAR
JEANS ONE DAY A YEAR.
THIS IS A CULTURAL PROBLEM.
AND WE MUST SHIFT THAT CULTURE
IN OUR SOCIETY WE MUST DO IT
WITH OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS WE
MUST DO IT WITH OUR CHILDREN.
WE MUST MAKE SURE THAT AS WE
MOVE IN THE FUTURE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF BEHAVIOR
THAT SOCIETY MAKES VERY CLEAR IT
WILL NOT ACCEPT UNDER ANY
CONDITIONS AND SO IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR US TO RECOGNIZE.
THE THE EVENT ITS IMPACT ON THE
WOMEN WHO ARE VICTIMIZED OR
OTHERS WHO ARE RAPED WE KNOW
THAT WOMEN ARE NOT.
EXCLUSIVELY THE VICTIMS OF THIS
KIND OF HUMILIATION AND
SUBJUGATION AND VIOLENCE BUT WE
MUST AS A SOCIETY AND AS A
LEGISLATURE BE AWARE OFF AND
CONCERNED ABOUT AND TAKE ACTION.
BASED UPON THE REALITIES THAT
THIS IS NOT A CRIME.
OF SEX THIS IS A CRIME OF
VIOLENCE.
AND THIS IS A CRIME OF
HUMILIATION AND SUBJUGATION AND
SO WHAT MANY OF US WARD CHANGE
YESTERDAY.
CHANGE OR FUND WHERE.
BUT THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE AND
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER GOING
FORWARD THAT THIS BEHAVIOR HAS
GOT TO BE STOPPED AND WE ARE IN
A POSITION AS POLICY MAKERS TO
ASSIST IN THAT EFFORT AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCHSENATE JACKSON
MEMBERS WE LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO SENATOR
SKINNER AND WE LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR STONE.
THE MORNING.
THANK YOU -- MISTER PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I ALSO STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION AND I THANK
MY COLLEAGUES FOR SPEAKING TO
AND I APPRECIATE THAT -- OR
SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA
REFERENCED THAT IT IS NOT ONLY
WOMEN WHO ARE SUBJECT TO THIS
CRIME.
AND I THINK THAT WE IN A FUNNY
WAY THE CHOICES OF WORDS WE USE --
THEY HAVE A FACTOR IN OUR
LOOKING AT THIS CRIME AND BY
CALLING IT SEXUAL ASSAULT WELL
THAT IS ACCURATE.
IT IS IT IT IS VIOLENCE AND IT
IS SUBJUGATION.
AND IN FACT -- MEN.
AND TRANSGENDERED PEOPLE ARE
SUBJECT TO THIS CRIME IN GREAT
NUMBERS AND REPORT AT EVEN A
LOWER PERCENTAGE THAN WOMEN DO
SO WHILE WE KNOW THAT THE VERY
REPORT OF RAPE AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
IS LOW AND LOW FOR WOMEN IT IS
EVEN LOWER FOR MEN AND
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WHY BECAUSE
OF THE SHAME.
AROUND SUCH A CRIME BECAUSE OF
THE FEAR THAT YOU BE CONSIDERED
THAT IT YOU ASKED FOR IT FOR IT
IS YOUR FAULT OR THAT YOU WOULD
NOT BE BELIEVED.
SO I THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR US TO LOOK AT THIS THROUGH A
GENDER NEUTRAL LANDS AND TO LOOK
AT IT FROM THE POINT OF VIEW OF
THE VIOLENCE AND THE SUBJUGATION.
THAT SUCH A CRIME IS REALLY
ABOUT AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
IT'S TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR STONE GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR -- I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE THE
SENATOR FROM BALDWIN PARK FOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
YOU KNOW THIS PAST WEEK -- THOSE
OF THE JEWISH FAITH INCLUDING
MYSELF CELEBRATED PASSOVER AND
MY KIDS WERE YOUNG.
AND COMING TO THE TABLE HUNGRY.
WE WOULD HAVE TO READ THE HOT
I'D TELL THE STORY ABOUT HOW THE
THE JEWS -- LEFT BONDAGE IN
EGYPT TO ISRAEL AND I REMEMBER
ONE OF MY KIDS AT A ON THAT WHY
CAN'T WE JUST GET TO THE MATZAH
BALL SOUP IN THE CA FELT THE
FISH WHETHER WE HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THIS LONG STORY ALL OVER
I'M HUNGRY.
AND I SAID AS WE CAN WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
THE STRUGGLES AND WHY -- WE
CHERISH OUR FREEDOMS AND IN OUR
LIBERTIES.
WHEN I FIRST CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN IS WHEN I FIRST LEARNED
ABOUT THE SIGNIFICANCE OF DENIM
I THINK WAS?
THE SENATOR FROM SANTA BARBARA
THAT EDUCATED ME ABOUT THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF THAT AND IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT THAT STORY
CONTINUE TO BE TOLD AND I
SUPPORTED IT EVERY YEAR THAT
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND IT'S GREAT FOR THE NEW
MEMBERS TO HEAR THAT STORY
BECAUSE WE NEED TO PERPETUATE
THE MEMORY AS TO WHY WE
CELEBRATE.
IT THE THE THE THE OCCASION WAS
WEARING DOWN WHICH I PROBABLY --
DID YESTERDAY I WAS ALSO GOING
TO MENTION THIS IS NOT A CRIME
OF JUST -- OF WOMEN IS A CRIME
THAT -- MEN INDOOR TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE INDOOR AS WELL.
AND ALSO WHEN I WAS ON THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I LEARNED IT OUR SEXUAL
ASSAULT RESPONSE TEAM.
WAS NOT FUNCTIONING WHICH MEANT
THAT.
MEN AND WOMEN OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
COULDN'T COME INTO OUR COUNTY
HOSPITAL.
WITH TRAINERS PRACTITIONERS TO
GATHER THE EVIDENCE SO THAT WE
COULD PROSECUTE THAT 20% OR 30%
OF PEOPLE THAT.
WANT TO GO AFTER THE
PERPETRATORS OF THE CRIMES WERE
HAPPY.
TO WHEN I FIRST -- ROLLS ON THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AT THE FUND
THAT PROGRAM NOT VERY PROUD TO
SAY THAT PROGRAM REMAINS FUNDED
TODAY AND THAT.
WE HAVE BETWEEN THIRTY AND SIXTY
CASES EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO GIVE THAT
EVIDENCE TO THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SO HE CAN PROSECUTE
THESE VERY HEINOUS CRIMES.
SO MY FRIENDS I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION -- I AM
VERY.
EXCITED TODAY BECAUSE I HAVE ONE
DAUGHTER.
AND MY GOAL WAS ALWAYS RAISE MY
DAUGHTER IN A SAFER ENVIRONMENT
THAT I GREW UP.
MY DAUGHTER IS A LABOR WITH HER
TWIN GIRLS TODAY IN HONOR MY
TWIN GIRLS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
COMING THIS AFTERNOON I HOPE.
I WANT TO SHOULD I WANT HER TO
REMEMBER THEIR GRANDFATHER STOOD
UP TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAD A
SAFER.
COMMUNITY THAT RECOGNIZE THE
HEINOUS CRIMES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
PUBLISHER FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MRS SENATOR AN
EARLY CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND
YOUR ENTIRE FAMILY.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE CENTER RUBIO
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU.
BUT BECAUSE I NEED SOME PRACTICE
I WOULD LIKE TO ADD THINK THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM CHINO SANTA
BARBARA BURKE D. IN.
THE MACULA FOR A HIGHLIGHTING
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS ISSUE AND
I HOPE THAT THAT WE CAN ALL
UNITE.
ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THANK
YOU WITH THAT I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO UTILIZE SEEN OUR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NO OBJECTION FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
AND ALL SENATORS.
MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO WHICH IS
BEEN DISPENSED WITH EARLIER BY
CENTER HUESO.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE SENATOR
ALLEN.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FOUR SENATOR CAFIERO.
COMPARED TO PRESENT MISTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
SENATE RESOLUTION TWENTY NINE BY
SENATOR CAFIERO RELATIVE TO
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION MONTH
SENATE CAREER ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
AND SENATORS I RISE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS. TO
PRESENT SR TWENTY NINE WHICH
RECOGNIZES THE MONTH OF APRIL
TWENTY NINETEEN AS CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH.
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT
CONTINUES TO POSE A SERIOUS AND
CRITICAL THREAT TO OUR NATION'S
CHILDREN.
ACCORDING TO THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN APPROXIMATELY SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN IN
CALIFORNIA. SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA WERE
FOUND TO BE VICTIMS OF CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT.
OF THOSE SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
CHILDREN. SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY PERISHED.
THESE ARE OUR CHILDREN.
ARE NIECES NEPHEWS NEIGHBORS AND
GRAND CHILDREN.
OUR CHILDREN DESERVE TO GROW UP
IN A SAFE AND NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT AWAY FROM FEAR ABUSE
AND NEGLECT.
THEY SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE MEDICAL CARE
COUNSELING AND A SAFE PLACE TO
CALL HOME.
CHILD ABUSE AND NEGLECT CAN HAVE
LONG TERM SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES IT IS IMPORTANT TO
EDUCATE OUR SCHOOL PERSONNEL
FACE BASED ORGANIZATIONS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS ABOUT THE
DANGER SIGNS.
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO HELP
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS.
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO HELP
CHILDREN THAT MAY BE AT RISK AND
PARENTS THAT MAY BE IN CRISIS TO
HELP ALLEVIATE.
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL PHYSIOLOGICAL
AND ECONOMIC COSTS THAT FOLLOW
ABUSE IN RECENT YEARS.
PREVENT CHILD ABUSE AMERICA THE
CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY RESOURCE
ASSOCIATION.
AND MANY OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE ORGANIZED A BLUE RIBBON
CAMPAIGNS TO INCREASE PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF CHILD ABUSE AND
PROMOTE WAYS TO PREVENT SUCH
ABUSE.
EACH YEAR THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES ISSUES A
PROCLAMATION ANNOUNCING APRIL AS
NATIONAL CHILD ABUSE PREVENTION
MONTH.
IN SOLIDARITY THE BLUE PEN
WHEELS ARE DISPLAYED ALL ACROSS
THE NATION.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY IN THE
OBSERVATION OF CHILD ABUSE
PREVENTION MONTH WHICH
ENCOURAGES CALIFORNIANS TO
SUPPORT CHILDREN AND PARENTS AND
BRING IN AWARENESS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
MEMBERS WE HAVE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
LAST CALL FOR DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
HEARING SEEN NINE SENATORS IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO UTILIZING
OUR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THIS
ITEM.
HEARING SEEN NO OBJECTION EYES
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WOULD LIKE TO ADVANCE THE
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE SENATOR VALLEY
PREPARED TO PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SIX SENATOR STERN HE PREPARED TO
PRESENT.
PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM.
EIGHTY SEVEN WILK.
PASS ON FILE.
MR MAJORITY LEADER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ANNOUNCE OF THE LIFTING OF A
CALL YEAH I'D LIKE TO LIVE THE
CALL AND FATHER MEMBERS SEVENTY
TWO SB.
SEVEN SEVENTEEN SENATORS WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO LIFT THE CALL
AND ITEM.
SEVENTY TO LIFT THE CALL AND
ITEM SEVENTY TWO MISTER
SECRETARY.
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BY BATES [inaudible]
I BILL.
BY FOR JUST [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
HI THERE ALSO [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
I TITLE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR HI MITCHELL.
BY MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK.
I MORRELL.
AYE NIELSEN [inaudible]
BY PM.
BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH BY [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
I STERN [inaudible]
HI.
STONE NOTE I BY KELSEY.
BY WIENER.
HI [inaudible]
WILK NOTIFY.
MEMBERS AYE AYES THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE TO OUR CONSENT COUNTER.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ITEMS ON OUR CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL 251-240-2306
351-366-3995 FIFTY SEVEN SIX
SIXTY FOUR AND SENATE BILL.
SEVEN ELEVEN MISTER SECRETARY
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA ATKINS [inaudible]
I BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
I POOR JUST.
HI BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
KAI DODD.
I DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER.
BY GROWTH.
BY HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
AYE -- TITLE.
I JACKSON I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING.
AYE MOORLACH.
HIGH MORALE.
AYE NIELSEN.
AYE PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
AYE AMBERG.
IOWA CASKEY I WINNER BY WILK
[inaudible]
HI.
HI IS THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE
ABLE TO ASK.
ALL BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRS
OR COMMITTEE CHAIRS WHO HAVE
GIVEN ME COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
TO PLEASE STAND AND BE ABLE TO
ANNOUNCE THE TIMING ROOM IN
WHICH THERE BUDGET SUB WILL BE.
MOVING TODAYWE'D LIKE TO START
WITH SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
EDUCATION WILL MEET IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
IMMEDIATELY ON CONCLUSION OF THE
RULES COMMITTEE HEARING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MATTER PRO TEM.
MISTER PRESIDENT A RULES
COMMITTEE WILL MEET IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE UP ON
ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
SENATOR RAZA.
A A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
FOUR WILL MADE IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY RIGHT AWAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER WHITE
HOUSE KEY SUBCOMMITTEE TO ON
RESOURCES -- VIRAL PROTECTION
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION WILL
MEET TEN MINUTES.
AFTER GERMAN.
THANK YOU.
ZERO ONE ONE TWO CENTER PAN
THANK YOU THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER THREE
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES A
ROUTE MEET IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE AFTER THE END THE SESSION
AT ELEVEN AM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
SENATOR SKINNER.
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
MEET IN ROOM ONE THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN MINUTES FOLLOWING THE
CONCLUSION OF FLOOR.
THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER.
SENATOR DODD FOR WHAT PURPOSE
YOU RISE AND UNDERDEVELOPED
TRANSACTION UNDER PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR PLEASE PROCEED I'VE
BEEN ASSURED.
THAT -- THEY'RE NOT ONLY IN THE
HOUSE BUT THERE IN THE GALLERY
AND I'D LIKE TO WELCOME CASA
GRANDE HIGH SCHOOL FROM PETALUMA
THE HIGH SCHOOL SENIORS IN THEIR
SOCIAL STUDIES.
TEACHER LISA KANE WELCOME.
WELCOME PETALUMA HIGH SCHOOL TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT YOU'RE HERE
TODAY [inaudible]
MEMBERS.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO RETURN.
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS.
AT THIS TIME.
WE'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
WITH A JOURNEY MEMORIES.
CENTER NUMBER PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES.
OUR EYES THEY THEY ASKED WE
ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF LONG
BEACH RESIDENT AND VOLUNTEER.
EXTRAORDINAIRE.
LAURA MATTHEWS KNOWN AS PEPPER --
MISS MATTHEWS LIVED A LIFE OF
SERVICE FROM HELPING
ENTERTAINING CARE FOR THE
CHILDREN DURING THE DEPRESSION.
TO THE US ARMY AIR FORCE CIVIL
WAR TO WAS THE ONLY WOMAN
ELECTRICITY.
WORKING FOR DECADES -- IN THAT
IS THE ONLY ONE LECTURE XIN
WORKING DURING WORLD WAR TWO FOR
THE U. S. ARMY AIR FORCE.
AND ALSO AS A DEDICATED.
MEMBER OF THE LONG BEACH POLICE
DEPARTMENT AS A VOLUNTEER FOR
OVER THIRTY SIX YEARS -- IN
NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE SHE AND HER
HUSBAND GENE MOVED TO LOS
ANGELES AND BECAME ACTIVE IN THE
POLISH CATHOLIC.
CHURCH IN WORK TO REBUILD AND
BUILD THE FIRST ROMAN CATHOLIC
POLISH CHURCH IN LOS ANGELES.
SHE MOVED TO LONG BEACH IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY WHERE SHE
WORKED FOR LOS ANGELES.
COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SOCIAL SERVICES.
SHE SERVED UNDER SIX POLICE
CHIEFS AND AS A VOLUNTEER THERE
FOR THIRTY YEARS.
SHE ALSO VOLUNTEERED WITH THE
LONG BEACH SENIOR CENTER IN THE
VA MEDICAL CENTER LIBRARY.
SHE LOBBIED FOR MORE CITY PARKS
AND BELIEVE LONG BEACH NEED MORE
PARKS WITH CHILDREN COULD ROAM
IN PLAY.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER DAUGHTER
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN LARA WAS NINETY
SIX YEARS YOUNG.
AND LIVE THE LIFE OF SERVICE
SHOULD BE GREATLY MISSED.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES AND JOINING
ME TO ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
PLEASE ACCEPT OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES AND PASS THEM ON TO
THE ENTIRE FAMILY CENTER NUMBER
[inaudible]
MEMBERS.
IF THERE ARE NO ADDITIONAL
JOURNEY MEMORIES.
IT'S BEEN A BUSY WEEK MATTER PRO
TEM THERE'S NO OTHER BASIS.
THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT AND
TO MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU ALL
FOR AN INCREDIBLY PRODUCTIVE AND
I KNOW INCREDIBLY BUSY WEEK I
HOPE YOU HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND
WILL RE ADJOURN OR WE WILL
RECONVENE.
ON MONDAY APRIL TWENTY NINTH AT
TWO PM.
THANK YOU SO MUCH APPROACH
AMERICAN SENATORS THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM.
AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN MOTION
WILL BE MADE WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM ENJOY
YOUR WEEKEND.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR WORK
TODAY AND FOR THE WEEK